- À la place de ce grand Costco
qui va ouvrir ses portes dans
les prochaines semaines,
il y avait un 9 trous du golf
métropolitain d'Anjou.
Une conversion qui plaît
au maire de l'arrondissement.
LUIS MIRANDA
maire de l'arrondissement Anjou
- Je crois qu'il y a à faire du
développement économique
d'une façon écologique, tout en
et puis, faut pas oublier,
51 % des revenus de la Ville
de Montréal provient du non
résidentiel. Ça prend quand même
des jobs ici.
- Le golf qui borde le boisé
d'Anjou voudrait convertir
d'autres terrains,
ceux qui sont au nord du
parcours, et permettre
l'installation d'un centre
de distribution.
Selon la mairesse et candidate
Valérie Plante qui s'y oppose,
il y a d'autres terrains
disponibles dans l'est.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- C'est pas ça qui manque,
mais on veut aller détruire
le dernier espace vierge
dans ce coin-ci. Pour moi,
ça fait aucun sens.
DENIS CODERRE, candidat
à la mairie de Montréal
- On n'est pas obligés de parler
juste développement économique
ou juste développement durable.
L'avenir passe par les deux
ensemble.
- Denis Coderre, qui a signé
un pacte de non-agression
avec Luis Miranda et
ne présentera pas de candidats,
estime que le terrain n'est pas
propice pour un grand parc.
- Savez-vous combien ça coûte de
décontaminer ça? C'est une
ancienne raffinerie, là.
Ils ont mis la tourbe, ça parait
bien, mon fer 9 est écoeurant,
mais la réalité, là, c'est que
si on veut avoir quelque chose
qui a de l'allure, il faut
commencer par connaître
le sol dans lequel tu es.
CHARLES BERGERON, Conseil de
l'environnement de Montréal
- À ma connaissance, les taux
de contamination ne sont pas
suffisamment élevés pour
empêcher que des gens y jouent
au golf.
- Et s'il préfèrerait un vaste
parc, le Conseil régional de
L'environnement se contenterait
du statu quo.
- Même déjà dans son état
actuel, le golf contribue
à la biodiversité locale,
à la gestion de la température
locale, c'est-à-dire la lutte
contre les ilots de chaleur
urbains, contribue à la gestion
des eaux de pluie.
- Du côté de la chambre
de commerce, l'accueil
est plutôt favorable.
MICHEL LEBLANC, Chambre
de commerce du Mtl métropolitain
- Ce qu'on demande, c'est une
vision parce qu'on a une
occasion extrêmement profitable
si on s'y prend bien pour tous
les résidents de l'est de l'île.
- Le sort du golf pourrait bien
être scellé au lendemain
du 7 novembre.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, M